intérieur la parole est à monsieur
yannick moreau ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
avec les beaux jours les gens du voyage
voyage et pas seulement pour aller voir
les matchs de foot en vendée comme
ailleurs la grande majorité des
collectivités
tran soin de respecter les obligations
légales en matière d'accueil
pourtant chaque été la situation est
explosive temps les occupations
illégales de terrains se multiplient au
mépris des lois et des efforts consentis
pour accueillir dignement les grands
rassemblements estivaux
tout se passe alors comme si les gens du
voyage avaient tous les droits et les
habitants des communes qui les
accueillent
juste le droit de subir et de payer ses
occupations sauvages
tout se passe comme si certains français
était plus égaux que d'autres
l'exaspération grandit chez les français
qui demandent plus d'équité et de
rapidité dans les procédures plus de
devoirs pour les gens du voyage plus de
droits et de moyens de défense pour les
collectivités qui les accueillent c'est
le sens des deux propositions de loi que
ma collègue annie genevard et moi même
avons au nom des républicains déposé sur
le bureau de l'assemblée nationale
ça n'est malheureusement pas le sens de
la proposition de loi socialiste dont
nous allons débattre cet après midi au
lieu de prévoir de raccourcir vraiment
les procédures et de majorer les
sanctions des occupations illégales
la proposition socialiste prévoit
toujours plus de droits pour les gens du
voyage est toujours plus d'obligations
et de dépenses pour les communes
monsieur le premier ministre
arrêtez de matraquer les maires de
contraintes et de dépenses obligatoires
nouvelle fait confiance monsieur le
premier ministre fait confiance aux
maires de france donnez leur les moyens
de lutter à armes juridiques égales
contre les occupations sauvages afin de
garantir la propriété privée la
tranquillité publique et l'ordre
républicain
monsieur le premier ministre pour que
prévale l' équilibre entre les droits et
les devoirs le gouvernement
entendra-t-il les propositions des
républicains
merci la pole et à madame sylvia pinel
ministre du logement de l'égalité des
territoires et de la ruralité
merci monsieur le monsieur le président
monsieur le député yanick mon
l'assemblée nationale aura cet après
midi à débattre importantes concernant
le statut l'accueil et l'habitat des
gens du voyage pour mettre fin à des
discriminations à anciennes et
injustifiée je veux saluer ici le
travail important mené par dominique
raimbourg travail important en
commission mais au delà avec l'ensemble
des élus locaux avec l'ensemble des
parlementaires de tous les bords avec
les associations des gens du voyage pour
proposer un texte d'équilibré qui
constitue un progrès majeur en faveur de
l'égalité des droits en mettant fin au
régime administratif spécifiques à
mettre enfin à la dispense disparition
du livret de circulation et de la
commune de rattachement c'est un texte
donc équilibré qui encadre mieux les
obligations des collectivités
territoriales en matière d'accueil et
d'habitat des gens du voyage en
renforçant la capacité des préfets dans
l'eure dans les communes qui n'ont pas
rempli leurs obligations qui améliorent
les schémas départementaux et qui donne
les moyens de faire respecter les règles
de droit notamment en améliorant le
dispositif de cessation d occupation
illicite
il n'y a pas besoin de monsieur le
député moreau de polémiquer sur ce sujet
important
ce sujet les occupations de territoires
c'est très pro quo la préoccupation qui
est celle du gouvernement c'est de
travailler dans un état d'esprit
constructif avec un débat apaisé je vois
bien que votre groupe n'est pas dans cet
état d'esprit nous le regrettons mais je
vous invite à participer tout à l'heure
avec beaucoup plus de responsabilités et
d'apaisement
merci madame la mairie